fueron tan multitudinarias y
contundentes como era de esperarse y
también preguntarle cómo queda la imagen
internacional del presidente de jair
bolsonaro luego de esta jornada de
protestas
bueno sí muy multitudinarias muchísima
gente en las calles apoyándolo lo que
demuestra que el presente pese a todo lo
que está haciendo los últimos meses pese
a las amenazas y los ataques contra la
democracia brasileña pues todavía tiene
mucho apoyo mucho apoyo de la gente se
supone que alrededor del 30% de los
electores
y nos siguen apoyando en lo que es algo
muy preocupante porque veamos un
precedente que demuestra un desprecio
absoluto por las instituciones
democráticas en el país en su discurso
ayer en san pablo fue muy muy
preocupante porque hizo amenazas
directas al tribunal supremo- amenazas
directas a uno de los ministros no de
los jueces del tribunal supremo y dijo
él ante todo que no va a cumplir ninguna
de las decisiones
judiciales que
excepto por ese juez que demuestra su
apoyadores guía a quien manda es de él y
que los demás poderes de la república
pues no le importan en nada lo que
claramente supone una democracia
bastante frágil y ante los demás países
de la comunidad internacional pues queda
muy evidente que la situación en brasil
es muy muy preocupante tenemos que
recordar que estamos a un poco más de 1
año de las elecciones generales el año
que viene y bolsonaro ha repetido ayer
que está muy preocupado con la
posibilidad de haber fraude en las
elecciones siguiendo un poco lo que
decía trump hace menos de 1 año la
situación es muy delicada en brazos en
estos momentos santiago ahora después de
todos estos años de un mandato de
ultraderecha en brasil sino velasco cómo
queda parada de la izquierda no qué
posibilidades tiene por ejemplo el
partido de los trabajadores para los
próximos comicios
bueno pues hay que reaccionar lo creo
creo que lo principal no es solamente la
izquierda lo importante es que se haga
una reacción más completa más amplia que
cuando los partidos de centro e incluso
algunos de centro de derecha a la
izquierda en brasil es tradicionalmente
una izquierda muy dividida en varios
partidos que no se apoyan entre sí por
eso suelen llegar a las elecciones
en los últimos años
la estación energía es tan delicada en
estos momentos lo importante sería no
solamente que el partido los
trabajadores del expresidente lula pero
otros partidos de izquierda y de centro
o incluso de centroderecha se unieran
para defender la construcción y para
defender justamente la tranquilidad
institucional del país esto es lo más
importante pero claro ya como estamos
como he dicho faltando un poco más de un
año para las elecciones claro que hay
que pensar en personajes que pueden
participar de las elecciones jóvenes y
derrotar a jair bolsonaro y claro que en
ese sentido en el 1 de siglo es el
principal calidad